male narrator: This
is what the future of life
off the Earth looks like.
The moon is a
fully-developed commercial hub
and way station for traveling
deeper into space.
Anyone who wants a truly
out-of-this-world
vacation destination
can now look to the stars
and back down at Earth.
The first permanent settlers
of Mars
arrive
to self-building habitats
that produce air, water,
and food.
With a new generation destined
to be born on alien planets,
this is the next step
in our evolution as a species.
[soft dramatic music]
- Well, this is
the coolest thing I've done
in a long, long time.
Today, scientists are blazing
a trail to this very future.
- This is just
a remarkable structure
from an engineering
perspective.
- I wanna know
what breakthroughs
are being made...
- Water could be used
as rocket fuel,
so we could use the moon
as a refueling station.
- That is a big, hairy,
audacious goal.
- That will forge
a future to...
Here we go.
Life off Earth.
[dynamic dramatic music]
My name is Justin Shaifer
and I'm
an environmental scientist.
Since I was a kid growing up
on the South Side of Chicago,
I've always dreamed
of exploring space.
When it comes to the very
expensive prospect
of sending humans
to live in space,
many people ask,
"Why should we go?"
But as someone that's
concerned about climate change
and the health
of planet Earth,
should we be thinking
about moving to another home?
If so,
how will we actually build
an outpost on an alien planet
and then survive the lethal
environment of outer space?
I'm in Columbus, Ohio, to meet
someone who knows first-hand,
former NASA astronaut,
Dr. Kathryn Sullivan.
Kathy was a truly
inspirational figure to me.
I was an intern at NOAA,
the National Oceanic and
Atmospheric Administration,
the first time we met.
It was then that I saw
the possibility
of being an astronaut
as something
that was very real.
Incredibly, this prospect
seems possible in my lifetime.
To find out just how and when
humanity will accomplish this,
I'm catching up with Kathryn,
my old mentor.
I just remember listening
to you speak.
- Oh, cool.
- It made me want
to be an astronaut.
It made me think that it
was actually a feasible thing.
- Well, thanks.
That makes me feel really good.
Welcome to our planetarium.
- Whoa.
- We can project things
on this dome
that will take you anywhere
in the universe.
- Kathryn is a geologist,
deep sea explorer,
and was the first American
woman to walk in space.
She knows a thing or two
about life off Earth.
You spent a lot of time
in space, right?
- My total is, like, 23 days.
- Kathryn flew
multiple shuttle missions
during her 15 years at NASA.
- Once you're in orbit,
you have effectively
no weight.
To be able to sort of drift
in the air like particle dust
is pretty magical.
- But space is dangerous,
a vacuum devoid of atmosphere,
water, and oxygen,
everything we need to survive.
Do you think
the human body as is
is designed to tolerate space
for years, decades?
- There are definitely
some unknowns
and some ifs about that.
If our bodies are not sensing
a gravity field,
the calcium in our bones,
which gives our bones
their strength,
that starts to leech out.
- Not only that--
absent protective gear,
long-term exposure
to radiation damages DNA
and can lead to cancer.
- You can certainly
lose your life in space
and you've gotta be
aware of that
and clear-minded
about the risks of it.
- Much of what we know
about these dangers
comes from studying
the long-term inhabitants
of space stations orbiting
Earth.
NASA astronaut Scott Kelly
spent nearly a year
on the International
Space Station, or ISS.
As a result of this mission,
Scott experienced
cognitive decline,
damage to his eyes,
and even changes in his DNA.
Before we can attempt
to build permanent bases
on the moon or Mars,
we're going to have
to figure out
how to protect our bodies and
minds from threats like these.
- That's one small step
for a man,
one giant leap for mankind.
- But where there's
a will, there's a way.
[soft dramatic music]
- Mars now is, I think,
like the moon was in the 1960s:
A big, hairy, audacious goal.
I definitely think
exploring Mars
and figuring out what would
it take to get there--
I'd love to see us do that.
I think it's really wired into
human nature to be exploring.
To not explore our place
in the cosmos,
to not continue
to expand our understanding
at the largest scale
of where we live
and our place in the universe,
I think is just short-sighted.
- Three, two, one, zero.
Liftoff.
We have a liftoff.
- With so many unknowns
surrounding the welfare
of humans in deep space,
NASA is first setting
its sights on a return trip
to the moon.
The Artemis mission,
scheduled to launch by 2024,
is the first step towards
establishing a permanent
human presence at the moon
with the ultimate goal
of using it as a springboard
to the red planet.
A spacecraft orbiting the moon
will serve as a hub for
research on the lunar surface.
The goal is to learn
how to live and operate
on another celestial body
while
proving technologies necessary
for a mission to Mars.
But at present,
lifting people and materials
above Earth's atmosphere
is extremely expensive.
To build a moon base, we'll
need to find cheaper methods
and reusable equipment.
I'm in Colorado to visit
Sierra Nevada Corporation
who is working with NASA
on this heavy duty problem.
- Welcome
to Sierra Nevada Corporation,
home of Dream Chaser.
- Wow.
It's beautiful.
John Curry is the director
of the Dream Chaser project.
- Dream Chaser
is a space plane,
so it's just like riding
on an airplane
landing horizontally
on a runway.
As you know, the space
shuttle flew 135 missions
and it worked very well.
What makes Dream Chaser
different
is it is so much cheaper.
The space shuttle was just
too expensive to maintain.
We're lighter weight,
we're stronger
than the shuttle.
- The Dream Chaser's
clever design
and carbon fiber body
allows it to hold enough cargo
to supply astronauts
on the ISS for half a year.
With innovations like these,
it can be flown 15 times
before maintenance,
keeping costs down.
The space shuttle required
maintenance after each launch.
With the retirement
of the space shuttle in 2011,
the Dream Chaser
is now the only spacecraft
capable of delivering people,
supplies,
and science experiments
to the ISS
and then navigating back
to Earth
for a gentle runway landing.
It can also perform the whole
mission autonomously--
without a pilot.
- I believe this vehicle
is gonna be critical
to transporting humans to and
from space on a routine basis.
- Sierra Nevada plans
to conduct
six ISS resupply missions
by 2024.
And unlike the shuttle,
which launched aside
two boosters and a fuel tank,
the Dream Chaser's designed
to be launched into orbit
wings folded atop a rocket.
[rocket whooshing]
So what's the top speed
something like this
would reach?
- Orbital velocity
is 17,500 miles an hour.
- Dream Chaser
will circle the Earth
16 times a day at this speed,
but when it returns
and enters the atmosphere,
it practically has
to grind to a halt.
- What's cool about this
and very innovative
about this design
is this is called
a lifting body,
meaning the lift that you get
from his vehicle
is actually the body itself
rather than the wings.
- Unlike most planes,
Dream Chaser's actual body,
not its wings,
takes the full force
of the air pressure.
The underside of the
Dream Chaser is wide and flat
and pushes against the
atmosphere to slow reentry.
- Probably the biggest risk
for Dream Chaser is the entry
'cause you see
3,000 degrees Fahrenheit
coming back
through the atmosphere
to get to the ground,
so you gotta make sure
that this vehicle can survive
3,000 degrees Fahrenheit.
- The Dream Chaser
can land anywhere
there is a 10,000-foot
long runway,
which means it can return
to any major airport
in the world.
[tires squeal]
For the Artemis moon mission,
NASA is looking
at a radical technology
to house the astronauts:
Inflatable habitats.
These habitats will connect
to a core power module
dubbed "Gateway."
Sierra Nevada designed
a system
called the Large Inflatable
Fabric Environment, or LIFE,
that can dock
to the Gateway module.
- We have a module
you could actually
turn into a space station,
and that would be what you
would want to take to the moon.
- The habitat can
be folded in a compact manner
for launch and then
later expanded in space.
Once connected
to NASA's Gateway module,
inflatable habitats will serve
as a base for researchers
traveling
to and from the moon.
- The key elements
to get us to the moon
is we have to put
the infrastructure in place
to make sure that people
can actually stay there.
Once you've got that,
then you have
a permanent presence in space.
- Technologies like
these are forging the path
for humans to build
a permanent home off Earth.
narrator: In the future,
inflatable lunar habitats
prove safe
and reliable gateways
to the moon's surface.
On a weekly basis,
researchers shuttle
between the moon and Earth
on advanced space planes
with enhanced rocket boosts.
Travel time is reduced
over 400,000-kilometer journey
from four days to just one.
With the completion
of a permanent research base
on the surface of the moon,
space agencies approve
both the base
and the orbiting station
for commercial uses.
Space tourists can even enjoy
a one-week stay.
- With inflatable
habitat technology,
a permanent presence
on the moon
might become a reality sooner
than we think,
but with virtually
no atmosphere,
exploration
of the lunar surface
will require new technologies
to protect explorers from
the sun's lethal radiation.
The last spacesuits designed
to function on the moon
were custom-fabricated
for the Apollo astronauts
more than 50 years ago.
These suits were both
expensive and cumbersome.
I'm in Brooklyn, New York,
to meet Ted Southern,
the co-founder
of Final Frontier design.
His company is developing the
next generation of spacesuits
designed to overcome
these limitations.
Whoa.
This is pretty cool.
- This is where
we make spacesuits.
Generally during prototyping
of suits,
we work with NASA and
the commercial space industry
to make suits work better.
This is an EVA suit.
Extravehicular Activity.
So this is when
you leave the vehicle.
It's like a space ship
for one person.
- In the days of Apollo,
spacesuits were only worn
for a single mission.
Final Frontier
is designing reusable suits
that are flexible,
lightweight, and durable.
- Now, NASA's talking about
back to the moon,
but for a lot longer period
of time,
so they want suits
that are more mobile,
that won't wear you out,
and that can last longer.
There's no reason for a human
to go the moon or Mars.
Unless they can get outside
and walk around.
- The key to surviving
extreme environments like this
lies in the pressurized
EVA suit.
- It's like wearing
a basketball,
which is where the challenge
of, like,
how do you get a basketball
to fit a human being
and how do you get it
to move like a human being?
- Pressurization is essential
to surviving
in the vacuum of space.
Without it,
blood would fill with bubbles
and the body would puff up
to twice its size,
causing death
in less than two minutes.
But pressuring the suit
to protect the wearer
from the harshness of space
creates a problem
with agility.
So you lose a lot of dexterity?
- Dexterity, tactility,
range of motion.
All these things
are really important.
We actually have a tool that
allows us to test the gloves
without having
to put on a whole suit.
- Oh, really?
Nice.
- Want to check that out?
- Yeah.
Final Frontier won a prize
from NASA
for their superior
pressurized glove design.
- This is a pressure chamber
and there's a pump underneath
that will pull gas out
from the chamber.
Stick your hands in
through the ports.
- The chamber is designed
to create the same extreme
vacuum of being in space.
- You're at about four PSI
lower than ambient.
You're approaching NASA's
EVA spacesuit pressure.
- Hmm.
Okay, so this is the problem
that astronauts have.
- Exactly, yeah.
- Almost feels like
I have a robot hand.
Yeah, it's--
- I'd really appreciate it
if you solved that
Rubik's Cube, too.
- [chuckling]
Let's see.
Do you think that there's
anything wrong
how these things should
be designed for people?
- Yes.
[chuckles]
Um, spacesuits
are traditionally built
like big bubbles.
Theoretically,
there are garments
that could tighten
around your body
equivalent to the gas
that you're breathing,
which would be
much tighter-fitting,
potentially more mobility.
That could revolutionize
how spacesuits work.
We're gonna let air back
into the chamber.
[air whooshes]
- Oh, wow.
That definitely changed
very quickly.
But that's not the only
problem they're solving.
Moon dust is sharp
and very fine-grained.
The particles get everywhere
and can cause life-threatening
injury if inhaled.
Final Frontiers EVA suit
has a unique feature
to prevent this
from happening.
The rear port
can dock directly
with the landing craft
or rover.
Is this, like, an entrance
on the back side?
Is that how it's--
- That's right, yeah.
You get in through the back.
This'll allow an interface
with a suit port
so you can be inside your rover
and jump in the space suit
without bringing dust
into the rover.
It's also easier
on the astronauts
to get in and out this way.
- Mm-hmm.
- NASA's current suits,
you get in through the waist
and that means you have
to really--
- Wiggle in there?
- Contort your shoulders.
- It's like a dance move,
kinda?
- [chuckling]
Yeah.
And there are a lot of
astronaut injuries from suits,
but one of the most major ones
is shoulder injuries.
- From getting into--yes.
- From getting into the suit.
- Ted's got a surprise for me.
He's letting me try on
the pressure suit,
which is something
that usually
only astronauts get
to experience.
- Right now,
we have air flowing in
through the umbilicals here
on your chest.
The only place
it'll come out of
is right here
at your regulator.
If you kind of
push your head back.
- With my pressure balanced,
it's time to experience
what walking on the moon
or Mars might be like.
- Try walking around in there.
[dubstep music]
- I have no--I feel like
I have no joints right now.
- Yeah?
[chuckles]
- I'm like a tin man.
- [chuckles]
- [chuckling]
Well, this is the coolest thing
I've done in a long, long time.
I don't know if I've ever done
anything cooler than this.
With advances in new, flexible
protective suits like these...
- Hey.
Welcome back.
- The path to exploring
other planets seems clear.
[soft dramatic music]
narrator:
In the future,
EVA suits
for space exploration
are as flexible
and comfortable as wetsuits.
Skin-tight
elastic undergarments
apply stable mechanical
pressure against the skin,
eliminating the need
for air pressurization.
These suits also compensate
for lower gravitational pull,
allowing scientists
to explore
just as easily
as they can do on Earth.
- Even with protection
from the harshness of space,
astronauts won't survive
a week on an alien planet
without one living essential:
Water.
But the cost of bringing
enough liquid water from Earth
to support even a small base
on the moon or Mars
is astronomical.
This means if we're going to
establish outposts in space,
scientists must find
a reliable source
of water elsewhere.
I'm near LA to meet Dr. Dean
Bergman at Honeybee Robotics.
Honeybee Robotics is
developing cutting-edge tools
to help NASA find and extract
water from the moon or Mars.
Oh, nice.
- Why don't we go look
at some cool things?
- All right.
- We are developing
these technologies
to be able to create
a sustainable civilization
off of our planet.
Water is the most
precious resource in space
just because we can use it
for so much.
And the more we can collect,
the more ability we'd have
to really live off-world
and on other planets.
- In 2009, NASA confirmed the
presence of water on the moon
in the form of ice.
Some estimate
more than 100 million tons
might be found
under the surface
at the moon's south pole.
Not only will
future spacefaring pioneers
need this water
to drink and grow food,
this essential liquid
has another potential
important use in space.
By splitting water
into hydrogen and oxygen,
both of these molecules
could be used
as propellant for spacecraft.
- Water can also be used
as rocket fuel,
so we could use the moon
as a refueling station
on the way to Mars,
potentially.
- Honeybee's drills were sent
to Mars on multiple missions
to determine
what was below the surface.
In 2002,
the Mars Odyssey orbiter
detected large amounts of
water ice beneath the surface.
So in 2007,
NASA launched the Phoenix
Mars Lander to search for it.
- We were part
of the Phoenix mission.
The idea was to uncover
the ice of the poles of Mars.
So we would scratch a line
on the surface
and uncover the ice.
- Wow.
Well, this is a powerful thing
to be in the presence of.
- [chuckles] Yeah.
- And the Phoenix mission
discovered what
they were looking for:
The first direct evidence
of frozen water on Mars.
In 2018, the European Space
Agency's Mars Express orbiter
discovered liquid water
for the first time
beneath the south pole region,
so Honeybee
is developing a method
to extract the liquid water
with this: The TRIDENT drill
with Planetary Volatiles
Extractor, or PVEx,
and Vince Vendiola
is showing me how it works.
- So this is Honeybee's
large vacuum chamber.
It is a one meter by one meter
by three meter tall
thermal vacuum chamber.
PVEx is a coring drill
with integrated heaters
and electronics
to be able to capture water
from lunar ice.
- Very cool stuff.
The large vacuum chamber
is used to recreate
the same low-pressure
atmospheric conditions
found on Mars.
- Well, let's do a drill test.
Close the chamber here.
- Here we go.
- I'm gonna lower the foot pad
onto the surface.
- This hollow core drill
can dig into the lunar
or Marian underground
and collect water ice
and icy soil
meters beneath the surface.
[metallic tapping]
What's that noise?
- That percussion sound
is our cam spring mechanism
which gives us an additional
weight on the bit.
- It's kind of like
a space jackhammer.
- It's like a space jackhammer.
And our software is designed
so where we only percuss
when the system detects
that you're drilling
into something hard
so that we save a lot
of energy.
- Hmm. So it's taking
a core sample right now?
- Right.
So we capture our sample cores
and then we activate heaters.
- It's a process
to extract liquid water
on the moon or Mars.
First, the heaters
must vaporize the ice.
Then the vapor would be
collected within a cold trap
and converted into solid ice
for storage.
Without this system,
the liquid water
would instantly evaporate
and be lost.
All right, is there water
in there now, or?
- Let's see what we got.
- Okay.
- Open up the chamber.
[soft suspenseful music]
- The epic reveal.
- Hey, there we go.
- Oh, nice, nice.
This is the future right here.
The red planet has plenty
of ice,
some buried
just inches below the surface.
Using this technology
to extract it
will make a future life
off Earth possible.
narrator:
In the future,
advanced robotic
drilling technology
sets off a gold rush in space.
Entrepreneurs race
to prospect asteroids
and comets
across the solar system.
Autonomous probes mine
these celestial bodies
for precious metals
and water ice.
Once the ice is converted
into rocket fuel,
it is more valuable than gold.
Trading posts
and way stations emerge
across the solar system
to process this precious cargo
and further the exploration
of space.
[peaceful music]
- With a large source of
water ice identified on Mars,
building
a long-term base there
sounds more and more viable.
But what other problems
will scientists need to solve
before people can live
in a hostile environment
on missions that could
stretch for years?
Yeah, we are definitely
on another planet right now.
I'm in a desolate part
of Wayne County, Utah.
Here it certainly looks
like Mars.
I'm heading to the
Mars Desert Research Center
to meet commander
Marc Levesque and his team.
[door latch squeaks]
Hi, how's it going?
- Welcome.
Let's head on upstairs.
- All right.
Hey, folks.
- Nice to meet you.
- Rich?
- Rich.
- And we have, uh, a nice,
international crew here.
- This habitat serves
as an Earth analogue
of an early manned
research base on Mars.
It contains
the essential components
a future team would need
for a long-term mission
including living quarters,
greenhouse, science labs,
and observatories.
- There's a variety
of research that goes on here.
Psychological, geological,
astronomical.
- The water-parched extremes
of the Mars Desert
Research Station, or MDRS,
make it perfect for simulating
a mission on Mars.
- This is one of the closest
analogues to Mars on Earth
given the landscape,
given the isolation,
given
the sporadic communications.
- At the MDRS,
every effort is made
to simulate the challenges
of conducting research
in a hostile,
alien environment.
- Any outside activity
such as exploring the area
or conducting projects
out there,
we have to be
in space suits
and we have to go through
a depressurization
for five minutes
in the airlock.
- Science time.
[soft dramatic music]
- Okay, Justin.
We're gonna take
two rovers with us.
And these two guys are gonna go
in the second rover.
- Roger that.
- Hello, Hab.
This is Ares 1.
That's us entering
the airlock now, over.
- Leaving the airlock.
Hab, airlock is secure.
- The primary
scientific objective
of the first
research mission on Mars
will be searching for signs
of life, past or present.
People have been preoccupied
with finding life on Mars
for centuries.
In the 19th century,
while mapping the red planet
with a telescope,
Italian astronomer
Giovanni Schiaparelli
saw what he thought
to be water channels
and many believed they were
artificially constructed
canals built by a Martian.
But with the arrival
of the first Mariner missions
to Mars in the '60s and '70s,
scientists confirmed
that there was not
an advanced civilization.
However, recent discoveries
of geological formations
have excited them
about the possibility
that some form of life
could have once existed.
- All right,
so we're gonna get out now.
- All right.
- So we're heading for that
boulder on the second peak.
- The geology surrounding
the MDRS is comparable
to what the first researchers
on Mars will encounter.
- Just wanna be on the lookout
for any minerals
or interesting rocks
that we can evaluate.
- To answer the question
of whether primitive forms
of life existed on Mars,
future researchers will look
to rocks.
By peering inside these rocks,
they may find the presence
of biomolecules,
or even fossils of microbes.
[exhales deeply]
- We're at the top
of Kissing Camel Ridge.
We're gonna mark the spot
on the GPS.
Hab, I can give you
the grid reference now.
4249540.
Over.
- Yeah, this is the spot
for gypsum.
- Gypsum is a mineral
that exists on Mars, as well.
In 2011,
the Mars rover Opportunity
discovered veins of gypsum
in the rock beds.
Because gypsum forms in the
presence of water on Earth,
Scientists believe that bodies
of water once flowed
on the red planet.
The team here in Utah
is simulating this search.
- We're gonna
keep our eyes open.
When it's covered in mud,
no one knows what it is.
- On Earth,
gypsum has a practical use.
It's used in the home
in walls and plaster.
On Mars, it could also be used
for building new habitats.
- So you'll get a lot
of gypsum on these clay beds.
It's just pieces of rock
that push up.
- That gypsum there?
- Yeah.
Here's some gypsum, actually.
We've got a little right here.
Some is nice and clear
and pretty
and some is really cloudy.
- Hmm.
- So we'll just mark
the location on GPS
and then analyze them back
at the lab.
- Sounds good.
By examining the gypsum
in its surroundings on Mars,
scientists might one day find
evidence of life
and prove it also evolved
on the red planet.
Back at the lab,
the team processes
and examines the stone.
- Part of the interesting thing
about in being
in the simulation
is you start thinking
through, like,
well, what would we need
for this
and what would we need
for that?
But on Mars, everything has
to be either with you already
or you have to, like,
cut up cans to make it work.
- Right.
But I can imagine
when we first visit Mars
we're gonna have to have
scrappy operations like this.
- Right.
There's gonna be stuff that
you're, like,
gonna have to make it work.
And this is definitely
a great practice for that.
- While some team members
are working out
the technical challenges
of life off Earth,
others are studying
the researchers themselves.
PhD student Rich Whittle
is studying how human behave
when confined
for long periods of time
in aerospace environments
like these.
- What we're looking at here
in particular
is the psychology of crews
in isolated, confined
environments.
We're looking
at sleep quality,
profile of moods,
positive and negative affect.
- Will being cooped up in
isolation drive people crazy?
Any mission to Mars
would involve being away
from Earth for years.
A one-way trip alone takes
about eight months
and the first habitat
likely wouldn't be much larger
than the space capsule's
tiny quarters.
So I guess this
is one of the rooms, right?
This is very humble.
[chuckles]
- And then this
is probably the deluxe suite.
- The commander's suite.
Oh, you can see light.
This is luxury, man.
- I know.
I'm feeling guilty.
- Mark has experienced
the psychological impact
of living
in isolation first hand.
- I mean, Mark was stuck in
winter over in Antarctica.
- Yeah?
- At South Pole, yeah.
- So three months, or?
- Oh, no. A year.
- Oh, wow.
- It's a challenge.
You're locked in with people.
You can't leave.
That kind of confinement sort
of forces people apart.
Towards the end, personality
conflicts started to come out.
- One of the longest
Mars mission simulations
took place in Russia.
Called MARS-500,
six volunteers were isolated
for 520 days.
They even simulated the up
to 20-minute communication lag
between Earth and Mars.
The experiment showed
that prolonged confinement
led to sleep disorders,
fatigue, and depression.
Before the first crew
can be sent to Mars
for the long haul,
space agencies need
to figure out
how to overcome the tedium,
personality conflicts,
and emotional toll of extended
separation from loved ones.
- Crews going to Mars
will be training together
for at least a couple years,
so they're going
to work out the kinks,
they're going to find out
how to work together,
'cause that's the real key
in any kind
of situation like this.
- With Mars simulations
like this,
we'll definitely be able
to solve
the technical and
psychological challenges
of establishing a base on Mars
and forge a path to the future
of life in space.
narrator:
In the future,
researchers
at the international Mars base
make a remarkable discovery:
A particular rock specimen
completely changes the way
humanity thinks of its place
in the universe.
The sample confirms
that ancient fossils
similar to those found
on Earth also exist on Mars.
This rock reveals that
the complex forces
that cause life to evolve
are not uncommon.
In principle, life,
possibly even complex
and intelligent life,
may have evolved across
the universe.
- While the first
research station on Mars
is likely
to be small and scrappy,
a long-term base with dozens
or even hundreds of people
will need more in the way
of complex facilities
and buildings.
However,
transporting the materials
to build large-scale,
heavy-duty habitats from Earth
is unfeasible.
How can we build
a permanent outpost
using what's already
on the red planet?
I'm in Brooklyn, New York,
to meet a design team
with a unique solution.
- So this is Mars Ice House.
- That's a habitat?
- That's a habitat.
- Yeah.
- Rebecca Pailes-Friedman
and Michael Morris
run the forward-thinking firm
Space Exploration
Architecture.
Also called SEArch+,
they won NASA's international
Mars habitat
design competition.
- What we do is we design
habitats for humans
to be in outer space.
- We use indigenous materials,
materials that are native
to the planet,
and we create
a beautiful living experience
that's also functional
for the astronauts.
- But that's easier said
than done
in the red planet's
lethal environment.
- The primary goal will be
to protect against radiation
from both solar rays as well
as cosmic galactic rays.
The best material
to protect against radiation
is actually water,
which makes up most
of our atmosphere.
- And Mars does have plenty
of water ice to work with.
On Earth,
we're largely protected
from harmful cosmic radiation
thanks to our thick,
oxygen-rich atmosphere
and magnetic fields.
But with barely
any atmosphere,
the surface radiation on Mars
is hazardous.
High-energy particles from the
cosmic rays damage human DNA
and can increase the risk
of diseases like cancer.
- So like our atmosphere
protecting us here on Earth,
we thought,
"Why not build an ice house?"
We created
this double shell structure
for additive protection
but also
to have a bigger space.
- That is so cool.
- Part of our objective was,
like,
if we go all the way to Mars,
why should we live in a cave
or a concrete bunker?
People should be able
to look outside,
look at, you know, the
strangeness of the landscape,
but they should also receive
the daylight
which is very similar
to our own here on Earth.
They have 25-hour days
and they have about 50% of the
light we receive here on Earth.
- But a long-term settlement
will need dwellings that
are more complicated than what
can be built with just ice.
The SEArch+ team has
a mind-blowing solution
for that, too,
using the mineral-rich
Martian soil, or regolith.
- This is Mars X-House.
X-House, the objective was
to build with Martian regolith,
or concrete.
We mined the exterior shell
from the soil
and we mined
the interior pressure bubble
out of high-density
polyethylene
that we drew
from the atmosphere,
so it's like
you're mining the sky
and mining the soil
to create one building.
- Another crucial innovation
is that this habitat
is constructed before
the astronauts arrive.
- It's built
by the time they get there
and then when they get there,
they can just do the work
that they need to do.
- And the team had devised one
far-out method for building
these prefabricated dwellings
remotely.
- All the buildings
that we've been designing
are all 3D-printed.
- Wow, that is so cool.
SEArch+'s plan calls
for construction robots
to be sent to Mars in advance
to build the habitats
using 3D printing technology.
- There are no construction
workers on-site.
We have to anticipate
everything
that could possibly go wrong
and design that beforehand.
- But these
incredible structures
aren't just computer models.
The design team is working
with state-of-the-art
3D printers
to make versions of them
in real life.
Using a mix of materials
similar to Martian soil,
the printers build actual
free-standing versions
of SEArch+'s structures.
The future of this
breakthrough technology
is much closer
than I could've imagined.
- Like, we'll be
building a habitat
on the surface of Mars by 2028.
- Incredible.
And so--
- So--I know that doesn't
sound, like, close,
but that sounds pretty close
to us.
- I mean--and that sounds
incredible to me, so.
- [chuckles]
- That's absolutely amazing.
Innovative designs
using materials found on Mars
will pave the way
for the first settlers
to arrive
to move-in ready homes.
But what will happen
when the supplies they brought
with them run out?
They'll need food and oxygen
to survive
in this alien,
hostile environment.
For humans
to create civilizations
anywhere in space,
we'll need
to build self-contained
and self-sustaining ecosystems
that work like
our home planet.
But how can
we build water cycles
and farm in desert wastelands
like the moon or Mars?
I'm outside Tucson, Arizona,
where researchers have been
conducting decades
of ground-breaking research
to achieve
this ambitious feat.
- This is a grand experiment
in Earth sciences.
Started about 30 years ago
trying to understand
how the Earth works.
They decided the only way
they could truly understand
how the Earth controls itself
is by creating
a facsimile of it.
This is called Biosphere 2,
as we live in Biosphere 1.
- Dr. Joaquin Ruiz
is the director Biosphere 2.
It almost reminds me of, like,
a palace.
[chuckles]
Not, like, a laboratory
or research environment,
but more like
a science palace.
Can you tell us about what's
going on here in high level?
- Sure.
Right in front of us
is the rainforest.
You have a big ocean
and then you have a desert.
- It was an audacious idea.
Build a small-scale version
of Earth
in completely closed quarters.
In a matter of years,
they re-created
a wide array of ecosystems
that originally took billions
of years on Earth to evolve.
To succeed,
Biosphere 2 needed to
be completely self-contained
and sealed off with nothing
brought in or taken out.
- We have to recycle
the nutrients,
we're recycling our water,
our air.
We're recycling everything.
- In 1991, eight volunteers,
or Biospherians,
lived inside Biosphere 2
for two full years.
Like a future habitat on Mars,
Biosphere 2 had
to be perfectly thought out
and highly engineered.
The health and safety
of future explorers
depended on its success.
Any habitat on Mars
will need to remain
completely sealed off
from the toxic environment
that surrounds it.
But keeping it sealed
and structurally sound
is a near-impossible task.
Sudden changes
in internal air pressure
could destroy
the structure itself.
So the engineers
of Biosphere 2
came up with this innovative
solution called the lung,
and deputy director John Adams
takes me inside.
- We're going into the lung
of Biosphere 2,
and when
it was originally constructed,
they designed it
to be hermetically sealed,
but they knew they had to deal
with changes in pressure
and this is the device
that they came up with
to compensate for that.
- All right.
[peaceful ambient music]
Whoa.
- This is just
a remarkable structure
from
an engineering perspective.
- [chuckles]
I didn't expect to walk in
and see this.
The lungs are connected
to the rest of the Biosphere
by a series of tunnels
to continuously balance
the air pressure inside.
- What we're
standing inside of
is an extremely large
diaphragm,
and that diaphragm helps
to modulate pressure
inside the facility.
It has a counterweight,
an aluminum dish.
- Yeah.
- Flexible rubber membrane.
The combined weight
of those two is 40,000 pounds.
And the only thing
that's keeping it up in the air
as you see it right now
is differential air pressure.
- Wow.
That is pretty insane.
[soft dramatic music]
This weighted rubber diaphragm
regulates the two basic kinds
of air pressure at work.
As the temperature outside
heats up,
the air inside the Biosphere
warms and expands.
Inside the lungs,
the increasing air pressure
pushes up against the
weighted, flexible diaphragm.
Without the diaphragm's
flexibility,
the air pressure
would shatter the glass
of the sealed habitat.
In space, an incident
like this would be deadly.
As the air in the Biosphere 2
cools and contracts at night,
the weight of the diaphragm
presses down.
By reacting to the changing
of air pressure,
the Biosphere 2's lungs
continuously adjust,
applying the right amount
of force
to keep the air pressure even
throughout
the closed system habitat.
- This is where air travels
back and forth
as we modulate the pressure
changes within the facility.
- On the red planet,
temperatures can fluctuate
more than 100 degrees Celsius
over the course
of a single day,
which means a feature like
these lungs is essential
to any future Mars habitats.
And to sustain life,
these habitats must cycle
and recycle the air
for humans to breathe
and also grow plants for food.
On Earth, this process links
animals and plants.
Animals breathe in oxygen and
breathe out carbon dioxide.
Plants absorb that CO2
and discharge oxygen.
In the Biosphere,
this fundamental cycle is
recreated with the rainforest.
Researcher Laura Meredith
is conducting an experiment
to test its resilience.
- All right, so I'll show you
the rainforest.
[peaceful music]
So this is almost 30-year-old
tropical rainforest.
- This is beautiful.
- Yeah, it's nice.
Even three weeks into drought,
it's pretty green.
Some of the trees
are dropping their leaves,
the soils are drying out,
but really, you know,
I think this rainforest
is showing us
that it has quite a bit
of resilience.
- Resilience.
In the rainforest,
plants absorb humans'
waste carbon dioxide
the inhabitants breathe out.
This subsequently helps the
plants grow and in the process
also creates oxygen for
the inhabitants to survive.
Growing a stable,
resilient plant ecosystem
will be essential
to the survival
of any future inhabitants
of the moon or Mars.
However, the first
Biospherians weren't so lucky.
16 months in, the oxygen
levels dropped precipitously.
It turns out
there was something
the original designers
underestimated:
Microbes.
Microbes in the soil
and in Biosphere 2's cement
absorbed more oxygen
and released more CO2
than originally estimated,
nearly leading to disaster.
Fortunately
for the Biospherians,
they intervened
and used additional machinery
to pump in oxygen.
In space, an oversight like
this would be catastrophic,
which is why it's important
to simulate and fully test
a system like this
before building a biosphere
on another planet.
- Because it's a closed system,
you really need to understand
how your ecosystem works.
Biology is really incredible
in its resilience
and that's something that
you would really want to have
as a component of your
ecosystem on another planet.
- Can we create a closed living
system like this one on Mars?
- It's an immense challenge
to put together
all the complex components,
but I am sure
that we can create one.
- Thanks to the original
founders' dream,
Biosphere 2 is a reality.
And while this
living laboratory
has had many challenges,
Biosphere 2
is providing crucial insights
into ways humanity can build
self-contained ecosystems.
It's innovations like this
that will forge a path
to future
long-term settlements
on the moon or Mars.
I think it's really gonna take
the entirely
of society's focus
for us to really start
expediting the process
of getting people to Mars,
but I think one of the things
that a few scientists
brought up that I spoke with
was this idea
that we should focus
on keeping our home here
habitable
and not trying to run
to other places.
Some argue,
"Why spend billions of dollars
"to get to Mars when
we could be using this money
"and ingenuity to solve
existing problems on Earth
like poverty, disease,
and climate change?"
- Should we flee this planet?
People can't figure out
how to live wisely
and live well on this planet.
Think we've been given
quite a treasure here
in this little
third rock from the sun.
- But Kathryn also thinks
humans are destined
to set foot
on the red planet someday.
- I think it's certainly
technically possible
to have a sustainable habitat
on Mars.
And it's very--it's conceivable
that it could happen
within the next
couple decades.
- The technical challenges
are pretty immense.
It's gonna take thousands
of people to work on this
and concentrate on it
at the same time,
but we feel that
it's important
that humans see these planets
firsthand
and we actually will
learn more.
- Others look
at the greater good
that can come
from new breakthroughs.
- It's not gonna be cheap,
it's gonna be difficult,
and we're gonna need
to push towards a common goal
to get people to Mars.
And hopefully beyond,
eventually.
And every time we are able
to accomplish something
like this,
we can then bring
that technology back to Earth
and the more advanced
these technologies get,
the more advanced
that technologies on Earth get
and I think
that's hugely beneficial.
- And the discovery of life
elsewhere in the universe
could have a profound impact
on humanity.
- I think the odds of us being
the only life in the universe
is very low.
[chuckles]
I think there's life somewhere,
so that's again why
it's critical for us
to actually continue
to explore,
to continue to look outward,
because I do think eventually
we're gonna find
somebody else.
[upbeat music]
- As a scientist that's long
dreamed of exploring space,
I'm excited about overcoming
the challenges
that will lead us to become
a truly spacefaring
civilization.
Getting humans on Mars and
settling and a civilization--
I'd love to see that
in my lifetime.
Will I see it in my lifetime?
I'm pretty sure.